لوكاربي القضيه التي حدثت منذ ثلاثه عقود
بين امريكا وليبيا ثم اتفقت الدولتين على
غلقها نهائيا في عام 2008 بعد تسويه
للخلافات بينهما عادت الى الواجهه مره
اخرى بسبب صانع قنبله لوربي الذي خطف في
ليبيا ثم ظهر في امريكا انه المواطن
الليبي ابو عجيله مسعود المتهم بتفجير
الطائره الامريكيه عام
1988 بالمناسبه هذه القضيه كانت قد تولد
في الماضي لكن اختفاء ابو عجيله وظهوره في
واشنطن عدم خوف لليبيين من تكرارها هذا
السيناريو تحديدا مع قيادات بارزه بالنظام
السابق هذه التخوفات دفعت قبائل اقليم في
الزان لامهالي حكومه ادبيبه اثنين وسبعين
ساعه للافراجي عن مدير المخابرات في عهد
العقيده الراحل معمر القذافي عبد الله
سنوسي
[موسيقى]
نحذر كل من له علاقه وخاصه امراء السجون
بان يحكم لغه العقل
ويستجيبوا الى هذا المطلب الشعبي اولا
والا سنضطر بيد سنضرب بيد من حديد غير
مبالين لتحقيق الهدف وفك اسر السجناء
ونعلنها الان بعد مده اقصاها 72 ساعه
وهناك سببان للافراج عن السنوسي الاول هو
الاتهامات الموجهه لحكومه الدبيبه بتسليم
ابو عجيله واشنطن والثاني لانه من احد
الاسماء التي ذكرت في التحقيقات الامريكيه
البريطانيه المتعلقه بتفجير لوكاربي
ويعتقد ان له يدا في هذه الحادثه وبنبره
تحذيريه هددت قبائل الاقليم في الزنا
باتخاذي اجراءات تصعيديه في حال لم يتم فك
اسر اسنوني ورفاقه وقالت ان يدا من حديد
ستتحرك ما لم يتم الافراج عنه بعد انتهاء
المهله المحدده ياتي هذا التحرك القبلي
وسط مخاوف من ان يلقى السنوسي او يلقى نفس
المصير ويكون الهدف المقبل وهو الذي ذكر
اسمه كما ذكرنا في التحقيقات المرتبطه
بالحادثه
[موسيقى]